hello everyone and welcome to another
game from round two of the 2013
candidates tournament it's a game
between 11 origin and Boris Gelfand now
in this game as you'll see both players
made a lot of great decisions up until
one point where one player made a
decision that wasn't really great but
you'll see what I mean by this we even
have a photo of this encounter here it
is our onion on the left and gelfand on
the right it's a position from from the
middle of the game but it's it's not a
spoiler I assure you so let's see the
game and we will show the standings of
the other games after this game our
onion opens with Knight to f3 we have C
5 so the reti opening C 4 transposing
into the English Knight to c6 Knight to
c3 g6 III Knight to f6 d4 pawn captures
pawn captures and d5 seek after Sun d5
Knight captures on d5 Queen to b3 and
now with a double attack on the knight
on d5 and gayland has a couple of
options here he can he can defend with
east 6 he could retreat with the knight
to f6 but he decides to play Knight
captures on c3 and here Aragon can
definitely capture the knight
immediately but he plays an in-between
move before doing so so Bishop to c4 and
already will have a very interesting
position can black maybe save this night
somehow and allow Bishop captures on f7
for example can he played nice too
before save his extra piece and survive
Bishop captures on f7 it's a very
interesting position for you to for you
to check out so feel free to pause the
video here and try to defend this for
black I will give it a couple of seconds
as usual if you were successful in
defending this with black you are an
amazing player because it's it is not
possible to defend this with black after
93 for Bishop captures on f7 of course
we discussed the scheme to d7 and now
you'll see that the knight on e4 cannot
really be saved here wife and simply
Castle and black doesn't really have a
useful move White's next move is d5
so after something like Bishop to g7 d5
is coming and after Night Moves then
comes Queen to a4 chick and now the
queen is also attacking the knight on e4
after the King moves you can even do
another in-between move Bishop to Bishop
to f4 now the knight on e5 is attacked
twice as well and there really is no
good way to defend this if you defend
with Queen b6 then simply Queen captures
here then the knight is attacked three
times the rook is coming into the game
black is completely lost here so if you
decided that it's not possible to save
the piece then you are you were in fact
correct gets one played nice to d5 he
decided to give up at the night this way
Bishop captures and now e6 Bishop
captures and c6 pawn captures and now
our onion castle and if you look at this
position it's a pretty equal position
all of Galvan species are still
undeveloped and the King is still in the
center and here Gelfand decides to play
a very interesting move now
of course you're you see that your C
pawn is isolated it's all one one move
you might consider is immediate Queen to
d5 and this is in fact perfectly fine
but gauge one plays Bishop to e7 and
this is very interesting because it
allows Bishop to h6 now why would you
allow Bush up to h6 well let's see
better to h6 you simply prevent black
from castling
then of course the elephant had in mind
Queen to d5 and after Queen moves now f6
this was a fine idea and next is coming
g5 and then the bishop will be kind of
trapped on h6 but this is in fact
alright for white after something like
let's say rook roped c1 g5 now trapping
the bishop then iron and can break free
with h4 but Irina's thought process was
probably something if again fund allows
Bishop to h6 and then he obviously
prepared against Bishop h6 so instead
Bishop to e3 Queen to d5 offering a
trade of Queens and rook F 2 c1 Ireland
doesn't mind trade in Queens as this
will open up his a file for the rook
Queen captures a capture some b3 and the
bishop to b7 now so
if you look at the position now get
funded does have a bishop pair so that's
definitely in his favor but the light
square bishop isn't really doing all
that much and well but all in all a
pretty cool position 925 and excellent
square for the knight get it found
castles and now rook to a for which
ideas of either doubling and the C file
maybe he will double on the a file all
depends on what get found place and the
the c6 pawn is definitely weak so you
know it will be quite easy to organize
an attack against it rook F to d8 we had
Knight to c4 and now Bishop to f6 with a
double attack on the d4 pawn Knight to
a5 attacking the bishop and here rook to
d7 defending and further increasing the
pressure our onion plays a rook to be
four I would a double attack on the
bishop and here you can either move the
bishop which is what yell fun played you
can also go rugby eight but it kind of
seems like this losses to Knight
captures on c6 not directly after rook
to see it now with a double attack on
the knight rook capture some b7 rook
captures in the knight to e7 check and
now you have to capture rook captures
and c8 King moves and now look to c3
defending the b3 pawn after all of this
white would be up upon but it's a double
beep on it's very unlikely you would be
able to win this so rook to b8 was
actually a viable move but a pretty much
force forcing a draw variation so Kevin
doesn't want to do this he goes Bishop
to e6
we have Knight captures and c6 and now
Rock the b7 h3 making some breathing
room for the King King to g7 and now
rook captures Bishop captures and Knight
back to e5 Bishop to d8 we have before
and rope the c8 and this rope the c8
move was actually the move that lost get
fun to the game here you want to play f6
get rid of this night and then slowly
but surely improve your game you get
your King over to the center play Bishop
d5 and so on and so on here gets one
played
see it and here another interesting
position for you to analyze I feel free
to pause the video here and find find
the origins idea here so for those who
founded congratulations and for those
who just wanna enjoy the show here
Aragon played Bishop to h6
this comes with check and what's the
idea well if you capture the bishop in
captures then you get rope captures on
c8 Bishop captures and now Knight
captures on f7 this is what check wins
back the peace after King g7 Knight
captures here you are up two points and
you are you are winning this game as
white so King to g8 was played of course
guess one did not capture the bishop but
now comes rock captures Bishop captures
and now the the move you had to see
Knight to c6 now the eight seven point
is attacked the only point that is
preventing these double to be pawns from
being pushed forward and the bishop on
d8 and the problem is you cannot defend
this because if Bishop to b6 then nine
three seven check wins the bishop on c8
and it's it's all over you lose a piece
and the game throw after Knight to c6
Bishop to f6 was played and now if
Knight captures on a 7/10 Bishop will
capture on d4 but Iranian is not in a
hurry he pushes b5 we have Bishop to d7
and now comes g4g for a powerful move
especially to define such a move over
the board the threat is g5 and g5 is
winning the game
why is g5 winning well let's see if you
play something like a six with ideas
that if white captures then you're gonna
capture the knife then comes g5 and now
you have to you there's no way for you
to save the bishop you can't you can't
go here you can't capture the night
because then the pawn will be too
powerful if you play something like
Bishop to g7 Bishop to g7 is is
impossible because Knight to e7 check
came to f8 and now b6 and there is no
there is no stopping the pawn if you
capture then b7
there is no stopping this pawn from
being promoted to a queen and even if
you don't capture it there's no
to stop it with the bishop over the
light square because both of these
squares c8 and c6 are covered by the
East seven night
so after this g5 move you would have to
play something like a capture some b5
now the night is under attack
but now simply night's the b8 now both
this Bishop and this Bishop on under
attack and you will get two points for
the piece but it is it's not enough
compensation this this Bishop although
it's kind of locked out of the game it
looks the black King got at the game and
this the white will win this rather
easily
so after this g4 move Agathon thought
now I'm not gonna lob g5 gets one pushed
a g5 himself but it didn't help him all
that much iron and played h4g captures
on h4 g5 now g5 did come you know even
even the girlfriend tried to stop her
but there was no stopping it
Bishop captures on c6 b captures on c6
and now Bishop to d8 preventing the pawn
from reaching c7 but now simply King G
to Bishop to c7 and after King to h3
Boris Gelfand
resigned the game there's there's
nothing to do here he's gonna lose this
pawn and then the King was simply waltz
in the position this King has locked out
of the game you can ever push this as
the pawn was simply captured that's
losing a second point and that's simply
simply too much too much advantage so
yeah that's the game 11 are inverses
Boris Gelfand from round 2 of the 2013
candidates tournament I do hope you
enjoyed it as it really shows how such a
such a small inaccuracy here after
before was played this rook to c8 how
many of you would play this and it seems
like a reasonable move I want to
exchange a rook and then I have a bishop
pair against the knight and the bishop
I'm totally fine here and then you miss
an idea like Bishop to h6 so that's very
unfortunate forget fun but it it also
shows the caliber of 11 Iranians a game
and we did say we're gonna show here are
the results from round one and also from
round 2 like we said in round 1 all of
the games were drawn and from round 2
Carson drew his game
Vladimir Kramnik with the white pieces
relatively quickly and did it ask cause
and what he thought about chess nowadays
and could he as since he is now so much
higher rated can he make the game more
interesting but he said that he drew his
first game against towering and
relatively quickly and now his second
game against Kramnik relatively quickly
so he doesn't see much excitement going
on there
Greece Chuck also drew his game against
Peter Svidler and you already saw the
game as we analyzed it in my previous
video team or Java versus Vasily von
Schuch so after round 2 we have the
leaders in tournament 11 our onion and
Timur a job of so after round 3 or maybe
after four I will I will try to you know
add at the standings after every round
so you are you you can follow the
tournament standings a little bit better
but it's only wrong to do so I thought
it was necessary at Aragon and our jogo
are in the lead so yeah I would also put
any any useful links I found find about
round 2 in the description below such
one such will be about bitter Dodgers
who made the the official article for
round 2 it's a pretty extensive so if
you want to extend your soon-to-be vast
knowledge be sure to read it and I would
also like to thank Miller's pablovich
and I in the macula Chama Chung Sean
Kyle for a contribution to my channel
think a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here by now there will they will
both be from the 2013 candidates
tournaments thank you for watching and I
will see you soon from a game or two
from round three thank you